Leandro es una persona increíble
de un barrio pobre en Río.
Creó un proyecto de reciclaje en su barrio.
A finales del año pasado, el 16 de diciembre,
recibió una orden de desalojo
del gobierno de Río de Janeiro
que le daba 2 semanas para desalojar el espacio
que había estado usando durante 2 años.
El plan era entregarlo a un desarrollador
que iba a construir ahí.
Leandro empezó una campaña usando una de nuestras herramientas,
la olla de presión,
de la misma manera en que la usaron Bia y Jovita
y nuestro gobierno cambió sus planes
antes de Navidad.
Estas historias me hacen feliz,
pero no solo porque tiene un final feliz.
Me hacen feliz porque tiene
un comienzo feliz.
Los profesores y padres de la escuela de Bia
están buscando la manera de mejorar
ese espacio aún más.
Leandro tiene planes ambicioso
para llevar su modelo a otras comunidades de bajos ingresos en Río
y Jovita es voluntaria en la unidad policial
que ayudó a crear.
Bia, Jovita y Leandro
son ejemplos vivientes de algo
que los ciudadanos y los gobiernos alrededor del mundo
necesitan saber:
Estamos listos.
Como ciudadanos estamos listos
para decidir nuestro destino común,
porque sabemos que la manera en que repartimos el poder
dice mucho acerca de lo que en realidad le importa a todos,
y porque sabemos
que participar en las políticas locales
es una señal clara de que nos importan
nuestras relaciones entre nosotros
y estamos listos para esto
en las ciudades alrededor del mundo hoy mismo.
Con la red Nuestras Ciudades,
el equipo de Meu Rio
desea compartir lo que hemos aprendido
con otras personas que deseen crear
iniciativas similares en sus propias ciudades.
Ya lo empezamos a hacer en Sao Paulo.
con resultados increíbles
y queremos llevarlo a todas las ciudades del mundo
a través de una red centrada en los ciudadanos
de organizaciones dirigidas por ciudadanos
que nos inspiren,
que nos estimulen y que nos recuerden exigir
participación real en nuestras ciudades.
Depende de nosotros
decidir si queremos escuelas
o estacionamientos,
proyectos comunitarios de reciclaje
u obras de construcción,
soledad o solidaridad, autos o autobuses
y es nuestra responsabilidad hacerlo hoy,
por nosotros, por nuestras familias,
por las personas que hacen que nuestras vidas valgan la pena vivirse
y por la creatividad increíble,
por la belleza y la maravilla que hacen de nuestras ciudades,
a pesar de sus problemas,
la mayor invención de nuestra era.
Obrigado. Gracias.
(Aplausos)